what's up you little Christmas criminals
bro huh you little pancake neanderthals
you guys ready bro are you ready man
Jesus back you feel them JC in the
building
hallelu man look at that hair coming in
hot today boy damn I'm feeling a warm
front on my scalp Daddy I got that
freaking cake golin bangs with that
caramel apple back slap on the
neck I'm feeling fired up man man happy
Easter to everybody you guys ready I'm
ready welcome to this past
weekend this past
[Music]
weekend
and in our
world and
prise by the F of a song The Bri on the
wall
we
and Came Upon a
story Old Time
Magazine Came Upon a story in an oldtime
magazine that is born and graced man
that is born and graced uh and that is
um music and that is um that's two
things that I feel like I am dude dude
you know you don't have to be religious
uh you know to have faith I don't think
and I don't think you have to be
religious to feel born because I mean
you're obviously born dude prove you
weren't born okay show me pictures of
let's say your baby crib with nobody in
it
doubtful and also graced man if I look
around in my life enough man I feel I
feel that I've been graced I feel that
I've been graced man I mean I know I've
made a lot of poor choices um that
haven't ruined me that I've been able to
bounce back from I've had a lot of
experiences that weren't G that weren't
good that I've been able to bounce back
from um I've been forgiven by people uh
for wrongs that I've that I've that I've
started that I've created that I've done
and uh and I feel I feel graced man uh
I'm offered Grace daily daily I'm
offered Grace I'm graced with the
ability to be out here on Earth dude
think about that okay tr- existing on on
another
planet okay people are always saying
well life isn't a miracle and it's
science and [__] okay Mars dude we
can't find a [__] on Mars
they're always out there taking
Footprints from 70 Mi away and telling
us it's something dude you can eat a can
of [__] [__] you can eat a can of
[__] Russian piss with all that I
don't believe that dude you know until
they find a young buck or somebody out
there doing sex on another planet man
I'm just saying we're graced bro we're
graced with the opportunity to be here
on Earth and that's what I'm feeling man
happy Easter happy Easter to you guys it
is let me see the date here it's April
it's Monday now April 17th and it is um
2017's is the year and we're still here
we're still here you know there's been a
lot of things that they say could get
rid of us um I think people were a
little worried North Korea could be one
of them but them dudes can't get it up
okay huh them uh North Koreans can't get
it up they can't get erect they just
basically doing a little bit of light
Easter
fireworks you know when y'all came when
y'all shouting out out at the mouth but
y'all can't pop off you know and I've
had experience with that um you know
definitely some times in my life where I
couldn't get physically erect you know
erectile in the you know in the dick and
the lower penis and um one time I
remember feeling very embarrassed with
this young G I don't remember her name
kind of
taller big shoulders had kind of the
shoulders of a man really and the rest
of a more of a woman's body elsewhere
and uh and I was really struggling with
some erection and she's like well I have
a friend that can definitely get you
erect and I was you know weary about it
because I'm already 0 for one sitting
there with this you know a little bit of
a blondezilla you know a little bit of a
uh you know a little bit of a blonde
Squatch you know she was definitely she
could play tight end um for maybe a 10
and 11 year old boys team
and she um but she was of age you know
she was over 18 but I'm just saying with
her you know size and kind of you know
upper she had a lot of might a lot of
Might upper might around the collar bone
and she could have really Set It Off I
think they in a uh for a for a boys team
around the 10 11 year old age range but
anyhow um uh so she phoned a friend dude
you know she got all U game show on me
she phoned a friend uh uh this redheaded
gal who was kind of tatted up and she
came over and both of them tried to
really get me erect for a while and um
and that didn't pan out so that was that
was just double the disappointment some
shame really I felt and you know I mean
I didn't want to let the second girl
down that was really I felt like I felt
like she was letting the second girl
down via my erection or lack of but um
but that was kind of a trying time but
anyway man uh Happy Easter dude I'm
coming to you guys from Baton Rouge
Louisiana I hope that uh you guys had
some opportunity to spend time with
family or friends if this audio isn't
really solid well guess what dude you
can eat a [__] small bag of cat [__]
because I'm doing the best I can I
literally have my microphone set up on a
a cookie tray um and I'm doing the best
I can here from my brother's home in
Baton Rouge
Louisiana um I am we'll get into some
personal stuff here I'm uh going to come
in at nine months sober when you hear
this and I know some of you guys party
and you know do acid and you know doing
types I know some kids are doing butt
acid now where they're doing LSD and
they're you know suppository type of
deal um what else boofing that's blowing
cocaine pain in your butt and you can
watch that on YouTube if you want to see
some of that what the kids are doing um
I know that some people
are doing uh other types of things
blindfolding themselves and and getting
high and you know jogging and [__] like
that um you know but I'm not doing that
right now I'm just you know I decided
I'm going to stay stay uh drug free for
a while so that's where I'm at in my
life I don't judge anybody that can
still party at this moment um hell I've
done some poor I'm I'm in Baton Rouge
right now first time I ever tried some
cocaine was over here in beautiful Baton
Rouge Louisiana I
think um and I went for a run I thought
it was a you know a performance enhancer
I'd heard that and I guess at the time I
was training for a uh half
marathon and so I caught me a couple of
grams of um you know that white donkey
dust you know a little bit of brain kick
and uh and I went for the longest run
I've ever ever ran I ran for 11 miles um
cuz I never ended up doing the half
marathon because I got into cocaine uh
nothing will keep you out of a marathon
like a little bit of uh you know that
white you know a little bit of Saturn
sugar you know so I I remember just
running along the railroad tracks and I
would stop and do a couple bumps and you
know I did a couple grams and ran 11
miles um and then I jumped over a fence
into some people's backyard and they
were doing marshmallows it was kind of a
I don't know if it was a it maybe a
family event but they were older this
was the older people were still awake
drinking beer and doing marshmallows on
a fire and I hung out with them um I
didn't have a shirt on I was sweating
from the run and from the drugs and I
sat there and ate a good deal of
marshmallows high and cocaine and spent
some time with them
and they were LSU Tigers fans LSU Tigers
and so was I so we had some common
ground there but uh but anyhow I've had
some experiences here in Baton Rouge
Louisiana I'm down here spending time my
family is here I've been in Louisiana
all
weekend I flew into New Orleans um a
friend of mine was dis dis jocking
playing sounds hitting you know doing
the hits at a uh bar where the people
didn't give a [__]
I'll say that my friend is a good DJ uh
but the people didn't care and that was
interesting to watch you know a man
really putting all putting his all into
the wheels up there and seeing people
not really wanting to Back That Ass Up
You know um so I was trying to be
supportive of him and uh and I feel like
I was I had some good times with my
friends um then I went to my family's
house we did
crawfish I had two crawfish boils this
weekend and um if you're not familiar
with crawfish boiling it is crawfish are
basically they're like the Steven Avery
of shrimp you know they real gutter they
seem like they you know kind of got
their GED you know they kind of dirt a
lot of them got carry a little extra
dirt around the neck you know they're
kind of the Scottish of uh of of uh of
of of sea life they're basically the
Scottish of sea life and they are they n
they're a little bit nasty but you boil
them up you put some good seasoning on
them and man it's a real treat and
people get together and it's more about
the conversation you have while you're
eating them you know people sit there
and and you're making sounds around each
other and you know your eyes are really
you catch a strong hit of a you know a
pepper corn to the back of the throat
and that'll light your eyes up and so um
we did some of that man and just you
know seeing each other be in pain and
and share their feelings at the same
time uh that's really what it's about
and that's what brings people together
so I enjoyed that man spend some time
with my
family uh my brother has a a really nice
family here in Baton Rouge dude and
that's to me it's been really inspiring
in my life um I didn't grow up with a
family connection we grew up together um
you know we had four four children total
and my mother mother U my mother worked
a lot you know she delivered newspapers
and baked goods regionally uh newspapers
locally and uh bgs regionally you know
dropping cookies and things like that
out in the area you know out to people
in different close States and that
um but so we us kids were around each
other but we didn't have a lot of
connection um and I didn't really have a
sense of a family I didn't think a
family meant anything you know but it's
that that whole perception has changed a
lot uh as my brother you know has three
children now and watching him create a
family uh you know has really kind of
inspired me to maybe one day be able to
do it I have a lot of fear surrounding
that you know it just feels like a ton
of responsibility already even though
I'm not you know I'm not even near there
you know um but it's it just makes me a
little nervous man um just to know if I
can you know show up every day for my
family you got to wake up not just for
yourself you know and I can be I have
been in most of my life I've been a just
selfish you know I think about myself I
thought about myself mostly most of my
life I've spent thinking about me uh and
I think a lot of that reason is when I
think back on my life I've been selfish
because I was scared man um to be honest
with you I was
scared that that nobody else was
thinking about
me
so one of the reasons I really believe
that I was that I did think about only
me was
because in my heart I just I thought if
I wasn't thinking about me uh that
nobody was you know and it's it is you
know think and realizing that now and
I'm not in that place now I don't feel
like you know I've been you know trying
to you know get help and get past some
of those childhood uh ideas and thought
processes um so I can grow up but but
that's a tough one to realize you know
when I start to really realize
that you know I was just I was selfish
out of the fear that if I wasn't
thinking about me that nobody was uh
it's kind of sad you know it's kind of
sad to think that I went through a lot
of my childhood that way uh in my young
adulthood that way but but I'm happy to
to feel that I'm not in that place
anymore um and I'm happy to share that
you know to share just some of those
thoughts now uh and let you guys know
what I went through man but my brother
has uh three beautiful children one of
them just learning to walk and this
little baby is um she's a tall baby I
don't know how old that is you know I
haven't spent a lot of time around
babies because I'm not uh a pervert or a
you know I'm not a pediophile I babysat
overnight I have two nieces that are
older N9 and seven and I Babys sat them
overnight multiple times zero instances
or desires uh but this baby is a tall
baby um I can't even maybe 2 and 1/2t
tall I don't know how tall that is
really but but anyway she's just
learning to walk and she got big legs on
her she got real hardy in the in the a
kind of in the ass and in the glutes and
front leg ass whatever that area is
that's kind of top of your legs but not
your ass yet your you know your leg
basically your leg ass um but watching
her walk it's like kind of like a I
don't know if you ever seen a I don't
know if you ever seen a big girl eat a
snow cone in the rain but that's kind of
sexy um no I don't know if you've ever
seen a kind of a you know a heartier
girl you know maybe a yeah I don't know
if you ever seen kind of a thicker girl
get off of a a tilt to whirl or a
Gravitron at the
fair um and these are some rides that I
referenced last week but I don't know if
you ever seen a big girl get off of a
fair one a dizzy whirler or one of those
tilt to whirl rides and you know not
have her her senses about her and kind
of wobble and you know kind of lean With
It Rock with it on accident but that's
what it's like watching this baby learn
to walk it's like a big girl that just
got off of a til to whirl
and it's funny it's cute and it's funny
it's funny to watch and it's interesting
too when you when you when a baby's
learning to walk or when they take their
first steps everybody cares everybody's
like oh you know she's walking she's
walking this [__] is out trotting this
[__] is
trotten but it's crazy that the rest of
your life you walk and nobody gives a
[__] dude you know like nobody CH it's
not like my mom text me again
15 or 30 years later it's like are you
still walking how's it going you know
your grandmother calls like I you know
good to see you I was there for your
first couple ones and you're still using
your legs nobody gives a [__] the more
you
walk um but it's just interesting how
everybody gives a [__] when you first
start walking but the more you walk
people give less [__] uh for your
ability to do leg work
anyhow man it's been a joy to be around
my family and to be inspired um by uh By
You Know by my own brother to be able to
create a family of my own one day I have
a lot of apprehension surrounding that
um but I'm hopeful you know I'm hopeful
to be
able you know to to
continually you know surprise myself
with who I can be um and that's one
thing I that I think is neat about
Easter man it's about a rebirth dude you
know Jesus struck back bro you know
whether you think he was a savior
whether you think he was just a early
hippie or what do you think he was just
a straight up magician I mean he could
have been a David Blaine bro you know
but either way the dude inspired people
and either way he struck back a lot of
people thought he he ghosted and then he
literally ghosted him bro showed back up
you know and I like ghosts dude and a
matter of fact I love ghosts bro I love
ghosts I've always I've always loved
ghosts and I mean they busted a man in
our town trying to be a ghost I've told
you guys about that before they busted a
man running a um a motel hotel and he
was trying to be a ghost and they busted
him and I was infatuated with ghost
since I was a child love ghosts always
love ghosts I love ghost pretty much and
and that's the like Jesus struck back
man you know and that's what a lot of
stories in life are about are about you
know everybody thinking you're down and
out and then you roll a rock you roll
away to rock in front of the cave like
JC he hit them and you pop back out you
know and and I hope that you know that I
continue in my life to
be kind of reborn into new ideas you
know and things that I'm afraid of at
one point that I'm amazed at how I get
reborn into a new mindset that I'm not
afraid anymore U that's one cool thing
about getting older I know some of you
guys have have dropped some calls onto
the hotline about you know being scared
and being in your early 20s and not
knowing Direction and stuff like that
bro just find a little bit of faith it
doesn't have to be in in a specific
religion but it can be in a higher power
of any of any higher power you create
and and just find just have some faith
that things will be revealed to you uh
you know a new mindset can be revealed
to you and you can strike back dude you
know you can you can you can Jesus a
little bro you know what I'm saying lean
With It Rock with it bro you know
sometimes you you don't got your legs
but then that you know that tilt to
world you know that tilt towar fever
that tilter world fever wears off of a
big girl and she out trotting now you
know now she's out with her girls you
know and they out there trotting and
drinking liquor so so I'm just happy to
continually be uh amazed and have new
new new ideas reborn into my mind man uh
and and happy Easter on that note dude
to everybody you know I watch some kids
look for eggs and do all of that and
they were fighting over the eggs and you
know some people got very
totalitarian I was at an Easter egg hunt
on Saturday and this was interesting
inter in we hit all the eggs for the
kids for the children and then we go
back out there a little while later one
of the neighbors I guess who was
probably an
alcoholic had come over opened up half
the eggs in the yard dude eating some
candies leave rappers about and just
jetted bro just jetted I mean that's
some who does that who wanders into a
children's Easter egg hunt liquored up
snacks out on half them hos and Jets bro
knowing that this [__] is for
children dude man you know if I got one
request for the Jesus Christ hotline it
is to uh fire some lightning at that
little devil okay CU that's no way to
behave dude I mean I've made some poor
choices but that is just straight up
gutter eating just out the just just
it's just that's dark that's the dark
arts let's crack into some news man um
did you know that Emma Morano has left
the Earth she was alive for 117 years
old she was the last human that was born
in the 1800s that was still alive and
she's gone uh she just passed away I
believe this past weekend and she
accredits uh her
longevity on this planet to raw eggs and
cookies and to um get getting out of an
abusive
marriage and that's uh you know we we
can all be in some abusive relationships
you know I mean I've been I've been
probably an emotional I've been
emotionally abusive um relationships
that I've been in um you know and I feel
lucky that that some of them GS ain't in
the relationship with me anymore so
that's you know I can I can I can
associate with that but uh but that's
what she accredits her 117 years too so
if you're cooking your eggs dude might
want to change that up if you vegan and
or if you're non cookie Teran you might
want to cookie up and if you're an
abusive relationship dude you might want
to take those boxing gloves off and uh
and step outside of it bro you could
live to 117 I don't if I want to live
that old bro you know at that point cuz
here's the thing even your own
kids have probably died so you're
sitting there there talking to people
who you [__] don't there's no way you
could know any of them or what they're
talking about um I mean every moment of
your life must feel like you're at the
DMV you know you're just kind of waiting
for [__] and you don't really know who
else is [__] around and and you're 10
and something years old uh but kudos to
her man Emma Morano an Italian lady 117
years old old um I'm going to drop some
dates on you guys I'm going to get into
a few calls I'm not making this a long
past tonight because it's Easter and I
want to get some rest and I got to fly
to uh back to Los Angeles in the morning
uh I'm going to let you guys know I'll
be at the punch line in
Sacramento um this weekend that's April
21st through
23rd uh I will be in Tampa that's May
25th through 28th at Sid Splitters I'll
be in Pittsburgh at the Pittsburgh
improv June 1st through June June 4th I
will be at Gotham Comedy Club in New
York City June 23rd through
24th and then we got a new show that
we're announcing where tickets will go
on sale I believe next week or in a week
and that's going to be in a small town
of Wyoming Illinois and that's going to
be July 30th actually no that's going to
be June 30th I'm sorry June 30th that's
going to be a fundraiser uh that we're
doing in that town so I'm excited uh but
that's what's going on man um and I'm
happy you guys are here with me uh I
hope your Easter was great um and we're
going to get into uh to a couple of
calls uh so I can go so I can go to bed
honestly man all right man I'm tired as
a damn Amish birth canal guys so let's
crack into these uh questions here we go
uh this is from
Montana America fella right here hey yo
this is Brandon from Billings
Montana I am calling because I wanted to
get some
advice Billings Montana I actually um
semi- witnessed uh a man jump out of a
window die to his death he landed on a
Starbucks actually in
Billings um and you know what I think
the Starbucks even stayed open uh but uh
but anyway thank you for calling Brandon
onward how to get my wife to start
giving me some more head I mean I do
things in return from her or return to
her um I go down on her I even eat that
little uh little [__] okay wow buddy
uh if you're eating eating that little
bee hole man if you're snacking on that
balloon knot back there I think you got
to use a washcloth first I'm just going
to throw that out there you want some
more head from the lady all right
onward but I get a little half ass blowj
jobs about her jaw you know those kind
of things um give me some advice love to
hear
back all right man um all right
appreciate you
calling um [__] ailment you got
issues here the well
first you know this reminds me actually
I met a guy one time um at a
casino and we kept in touch and then she
came to visit and before she came in
town she'd had some type of
surgery um and she'd broken her jaw
right before she came to visit me and uh
and she had she couldn't open her mouth
all the
way so if if we tried to do some moral
sex I kind of had to
really kind of feed my penis in there a
little bit and uh and go from there so I
guess I have had some experience you
know I can share that that I've had that
some experience with some issues there
kind of had to baby birded in there
there a little bit into this gal's mouth
is Canadian gal um and uh and that was
really pretty wild she also had some she
had fake hair that was kind of cheaply
made could have been made in China and
it kind of fell out around the house a
bit and that was alarming but um but if
you got an issue with the wife not doing
it man first of all in some places it's
not even allowed so you can find some
gratitude there that even bad [__]
are allowed apparently where you live so
that's that's good um you could leave
maybe leave some things around the house
you could hide a you know leave hide a
couple cucumbers around the house or
maybe get a sign you know says [__]
are welcome
or um or you really want to do something
dude be brave w't you get her a maybe a
strap on or you know um external
penis um a a attachment you know and you
give her one you know fire up on a
little piece of rubber candy coming off
of a belt that's around her waist and
maybe show her exactly what you
want um cuz if you're doing down there
if you're down there really doing some
carnal work then it does seem like you
might you probably you don't deserve it
but it seems like you want to be
rewarded so maybe that's something you
could do man um
you know it's I think a [__] is nicer
as you get older uh because it just kind
of it's a different type of touch you
know and it's it's exciting to a man to
to see that and to be a part of it you
know part of the [__] is just seeing
it occur and that's really maybe what
you're wanting to see um but I commend
you for sticking it out with your wife
and you know wanting to figure it out
and not resorting to getting external
[__] or you you know or jerking off
into fake mouths you can buy a lot of
these fake mouths on the internet and I
don't recommend that I like the way
you're keeping it there within the
within the family
unit um I mean if you you know I am am
talking about family this evening and
blow job being going to get you a family
that's for sure you know you're going to
have to go guts on that you're going
have to get up in the guts if you want
to family up but if you're just looking
to get a little more head I would
suggest you know leaving some longevity
type vegetables cucumbers uh you know
some eggplants you know that's the new
Emoji there so maybe hide an eggplant in
the bed and see how that you know what
that starts as um you know get a sign
maybe maybe graffiti your house dude
hire a couple of you know dark artists
to maybe you know
um maybe right they ain't sucking dick
around here or something on your garage
one morning you know maybe just even
start the conversation you can start it
externally by uh having some local uh
Nells help out um now Montana you want
to keep her hydrated because that also
is the kind of country where you can get
dehydrated pretty quickly um but why you
call us back maybe in a couple weeks and
see you know let us know how how that's
going and if if any of these suggestions
are helping
out um but you want to create the
conversation you know you want to make
it a able conversation that you guys can
have together um and just let her know
you enjoy it you know let her know you
enjoy it I would maybe send her a card
that says thank you for the [__] you
give you know and maybe that'll just
Inspire her to want to do more get her
one of those [__] classes you know or
um there's probably videos on the
internet YouTube links you could send
her but sending a lady a link is pretty
it's not very classy I'd get her an
actual uh instructural course you know
they got some um ladies that do lectures
and stuff and even gay men you know that
do lectures you know or maybe introduced
her some gay men I mean they they do
blow jobs and maybe they could help
Inspire her so I'm going say good luck
with that right there moving
on what's up Theo man my name is John
big fan of the podcast dude thank you
John thank you for listening man um I do
appreciate it continue I had a question
for you you've mentioned I think in your
acting in several of your podcasts that
uh your brother tried to you know have
sex with you when you're a kid and you
ALS yes I'm going to say yes to that my
brother um you know developed this heavy
desire to do sex with me when we were
children um it was kind of uh you know
he realized I kind of had a hole in my
butt and he was really he got early on
set erections I've discussed that before
on
also mentioned uh I think a couple
months ago in your podcast that you were
out visiting him and his family and I am
I'm actually I'm at their home now I'm
actually I'm actually recording this at
uh midnight right under uh he and his
wife's
room um so I guess that is this is
interesting let's let's hear more I'm
just
thinking is that something that is
addressed you guys ever talk about that
what does his wife think about that um I
just find it pretty strange that he
tried to do that to you as a kid and it
seems like that would create issue for
uh later on in life but it seems you
guys are pretty close I'm just wondering
how you guys go about
that well I'll stop it there and just
say that I mean I think we had tougher
things to deal with um you know there
was you know we were it was a tough
neighborhood and in hindsight it was one
of the few
things that kind of brought us together
as children it's sadly it's one of the
it's one of the few Memories We have as
young children where
we spent time together was we me really
hiding my butt from him um you know and
I it is very strange I
agree um do we discuss it now here let
me you're almost done let me finish up
this question all right man keep up the
good work love the podcast uh I'm going
to come see you out in Sacramento oh
good um April 23rd I believe looking for
yes you are man that's this weekend I'm
excited about that um do we address it
we have we've discussed it um you know
there's been forgiveness offered and uh
forg forgiveness accepted on both sides
you know I didn't and also just an
understanding that we were children you
know I have um uh some nephews from a
different family um you know from kind
of a surate family and I walked in on
two of those young fellas nude in the
bed one time you know just just laying
on top of each other's bodies you know
and they weren't gay children they were
just you know young children and they're
they had a lot of feelings in their skin
at the at the moment you know and their
bodies just feel f fancy to each other
when you're young and you don't know
anything you know um we had a boy in our
town used to kind of put his dick in the
ground um and that was bizarre you know
and you'd see him a lot
outside always just laying on the ground
and you knew what he was doing you know
he was
doing just doing kind of [__] down in
the earth a little and that was just him
being young and so my brother and I have
discussed that it is funny sometimes
I'll see you know his kids kind of
fighting or slapping each other on the
butt and I'll kind of nudge them a
little and that'll take us back to those
times a lot of that was because we
shared bath time together um you know a
lot of families will do group baths when
you're young with the
children um and my brother was just
weird man he you know he got early on
set erections and it's hard to I can't
penalize him for
that and I really can't penalize myself
for being kind of a hot piece of when I
really you know if I want to think about
it like that um I mean I had another
time where one of my good friends and I
were under a blanket kind of feeling
each other's rib cages and feeling
erotic you know and now that's weird
when I see him because he doesn't wish
to discuss it and he doesn't want to
admit that you know we were both sitting
under these blankets being erect and
just kind of feeling each other's ribs
kind of like a you know like a blind man
at a at an
instrument um but that occurred and some
of that's just childhood stuff um does
his wife know about it that's a good
question she's heard some of my comedy
where I do talk about it I don't know if
she's heard that bit yet or not and if
he comes to me and says that he wants
that she wants to discuss it with me I
am open to discuss it um it's not some
stuff sometimes that I want to
relive uh because I just realize that
there's we can't go back in time and
undo some of that young attraction um
and in a way I kind of you know I'm a
I'm not grateful for it uh cuz it was it
was hectic dude you know knowing that
you know it was just it was like a game
of freeze tag that was going to cost you
really
some you know whatever Joy you currently
kind of held in your ass as a child you
know or Comfort whatever you know I was
worried it was going to cost me some
comfort cuz that I mean my brother
really he came at me with that with that
erection
and uh and it
was it it just was what it was man we've
kind of move past it I appreciate you
asking about it because you know I do
think it is interesting and I think a
lot of um a lot of uh children when they
were a lot of people now when they were
children had some things like that occur
you know um one of my sisters used to
kind of do little strip teases and we're
waiting in the car when when my dad
would go inside to you know usually he
would go get us a sack of Pies a sack of
uh slice pie slices from the Burger King
and one of my sisters would kind of do
some light erotic dancing sometimes in
the back of his car and that [__] was
you know I don't know what the hell it
was but in hindsight it was kind of
weird and alarming I guess but at the
time it was just children and you know
it was I just look at it as something
that kind of
you know we did and we were kids and we
didn't know if he tried it now that'd be
very much that'd be a bigger discussion
you know and I don't think we'll resort
to that unless you know the damn world's
about to end or unless um you know he's
married now and we don't have really a
lot of those feelings for each other you
know anything like that you know our
feelings now are just platonic fam
familial um and I'm grateful uh I'm I'm
grateful that we went through that in a
way so that if he sees that with his
kids he kind of knows how to navigate it
so we kind of took that bullet for our
family I think um but I appreciate you
asking about it man we got one more
question
here hey what's up Theo my name is Zane
I live uh not too far from you I live up
here in Ontario California Ontario
California they have a comedy club out
there Ontario Improv where I don't
perform at much Zane but maybe in the
future thanks for calling bud onward and
I just got done listening to this latest
episode he said you going to take some
calls on Family Life yes sir me and my
lady we've been together for 11
years she's going to be two this may and
uh okay you might not have been able to
heard that there it cut out he has a
child now that's going to be two uh this
may he and his wife who have been
together for 11 years onward Zane I mean
I just want to tell you man having a
child and working for a family I mean
kids are kids aren't easy but they're
not as hard as everybody makes it seem
and you know I work hard I've been uh
you know I've worked harder now since
she's been born than I've ever worked
but you know it's all worth it and uh
you know you seem like a good dude and I
uh I wish you nothing but the best I
hope you uh you find what you're looking
for and if you're thinking of starting a
family I think uh you'd be great at it
you know it's uh you know all they need
is a little bit of love and some diapers
and food you know you know what I mean
and uh take care and good luck man later
man thank you for that call dude um you
know and I know that wasn't a question
uh that he was asking really it was just
a statement um but I wanted to share
that because I thought that was just a
nice call it was a call of
encouragement uh and I need those you
know I'm I'm not saying call and
encourage me or you know U but I do get
some calls that are just supportive and
I want to say I I appreciate that man um
and this call kind of touched me a
little bit because you can just hear in
his
voice uh you know that he cares you know
that he that he you could hear some
pride when he talks about showing up um
he's got a two-year-old little girl I
mean that's beautiful you know I don't
if you've ever you know uh you know just
spent time around a 2-year-old little
girl but I mean it's about the sweetest
thing when they're behaving about the
sweetest thing you can
imagine um and just to hear this man
married for 11 years and he's got a
2-year-old girl and it inspires him to
to work hard and and to keep going and
that's cool man it's cool to hear I
think partially because you know I
didn't I don't know how my dad felt
about me you know my dad was 70 when I
was born and he was 86 uh when he died
and I never you know we we just never
got to have those conversations by the
time I was old enough to ask him what it
was like to be a dad some of the joys
that he had when he was around me as a
child he was gone so it's just nice to
hear um just a man excited about his
family you know we see all this stuff
about how families don't work and how
marriages don't work um but what we
don't hear about sometimes is just we
don't hear a man say that he enjoys it
and that it's hard work but that it
brings him some of the greatest joys of
his
life and I think about it you know and I
think about starting a family now I
never thought about it before dude um
and that's been one of the gifts of me
over the past nine months of not
drinking and partying for me has been
having time to reflect and having time
to listen to other people and really
hear other people and hear some of the
joy and hear some of the trouble that
they go through and to kind of learn
from it or see how some of those
experiences would feel in my own life
and and a and and starting a family is
something that I've thought a lot about
you know it's scary to me it's scary to
me to not think about myself sometimes
you know to think about that to imagine
that the part of my life
where just me and my joy is over you
know and that it's selfish to think that
I don't want
to you know provide or create a world
for someone else because I'm not done
creating my own world and that's okay
but but at some point I have to start to
let that teeter totter start to tip you
know um if if I want to have a family
and and uh and you know and this year
I've started to feel like I would like
to you know and it's it's scary it's
scary to think about what kind of dad I
would be you know after would I be able
to even be married for 11 years dude
that
sounds I mean I haven't been in a
relationship in 10 years um you know
because of commitment issues that I have
and stuff and uh so just to hear you
know that there's somebody out there
that's doing it and that is you can hear
the joy in his voice um it's inspiring
to me man you know cuz I think families
are important you know if I could go
back in time and have anything and my
life's been filled with a lot of unique
experiences man I've been really
really
blessed um I've been really graced had a
lot of Grace uh in my life and but if I
could have almost anything when I really
think about it it would be to go back
and have just a a childhood where I felt
loved you know um cuz I didn't have that
I had a lot of supplementary love that
came from um families that took me in um
and and I love my mother and I love my
father and I think they both did what
they could for sure um and no one will
ever replace my mother or father you
know but for some reason as a child I
just did not feel loved and uh and it's
just really nice to hear
somebody you know that's doing that for
their child and to know that that child
has a chance to grow up in that
environment um so I guess I just wanted
to kind of play that and share that and
just let that thought be out there uh
and to inspire anybody else that's
thinking about it you know if you're
struggling or if you feel like somebody
else needs inspiration in that realm
[__] share it with them man you know
don't be afraid to drop your joy on
other
people um a lot of my life for some
reason I've even felt scared to feel Joy
you know I think cuz I felt so
much misery or pain as a child and I
felt so insecure and
so just low
self-worth that when Joy came around the
possibility of even telling somebody
else that I felt
good uh that was scary to me um and
sometimes it still is man sometimes it's
still scary uh to let people
know that I feel good you know when I do
and that's a new that's a new thing for
me is learning to let people know that I
feel okay uh because
for a lot of my life the only thing that
I knew how to feel um and to navigate
was that I didn't feel okay you know
so um so that's another thing man where
I'm kind of being a little bit reborn
right there in that space where if you'd
asked me a year ago Dude you think you
know
you'll have you know would you be in a
year from now you think you'll be in a
space where you you know will have days
where you feel okay all day I probably
would have said no you know um but the
last year of my life's been kind of
monumental and the fact that I feeling
some opportunities to um have some of my
feelings um be reborn and have some um
just new ideas of Happiness uh revealed
to me and a lot of that's happening
through other people other people just
just sharing their joy and me being able
to actually hear it and feel it uh so
anyhow thanks for calling in we got some
other calls I'll get to them next week
man um you know but thank you Zane uh
thank you [__] and Billings um and
thanks for asking about uh the sexuality
with my brother and uh you know part of
it's you know it's funny to think about
the times we had I mean that was you
want to talk about hide and seek dude
that's that was about a year and a half
of hideand-seek that went that was Full
Throttle dude that's fast and furious
that's a Tokyo Drift of hide and seek
when your brother's trying to do sex to
you in the house um I'm going to take us
out this evening um on a song here this
is uh Victory theme that's all I know
about this I want to thank you guys for
joining me on this past weekend continue
to hit the hotline I'll post the number
at the bottom of the YouTubes uh this
will be on iTunes and then on YouTubes
later in the day on Monday uh Happy
Easter uh I hope it was a good one for
everybody I really do um and I
appreciate you guys so much for just
kind of going on this journey with me
and learning as we go you know um damn
boy I'll say this dude nobody could run
11 miles on a couple grams of cocaine
like your boy right here all right uh
let's take us out
man that's like a little bit of Rocky
music right there you feel
that it's a victory theme
[Music]
bro I said Victory
theme cuz Anything Can Happen man you
got to sometimes embrace the idea of
possibility that's what I'm
learning you know and maybe next week I
want to kill myself but this week I
don't and this week I'm going to take on
my day and think that anything is POS
possible cuz a lot of times I would take
my days like oh I know what today's
going to be like this is going to suck
you know somebody's going to [__] in my
car you know or you know somebody's
going to kill a bird you know and leave
it leave it on my
yard
but if I wake up thinking I don't know
what's going to happen today something
new could happen I could meet somebody
new I could think something new I could
find a new
a
new a new revelation in my life or in my
heart dude I know this [__] sounds a
little bit gay as [__] dude a little bit
GF but but dude sometimes you got to
embrace it sometimes you got to embrace
the the possibility that anything could
happen cuz that possibility man imagine
waking up just being like you know what
I don't know what's going to happen
today that's all you got to
do to create possibilities
just be willing to not know and I'm not
preaching at you man I'm also just
trying to remind myself uh to do that
tomorrow and to uh to open myself up to
possibility cuz I need it man I need to
hear this I need to hear my selft talk
you know that's really just kind of
sometimes what I'm doing right here um
but I'm I'm grateful for you guys man uh
you guys have a wonderful week uh Happy
Easter bro enjoy it get to it get at it
be good or be good at
it but take care of yourself man you
know and be good to yourself you know
once you try that I bet you deserve it
man you guys be swell bro I'm
out